welcome to the Johnny halter shooting
sports center what's nice here at the
range now is this lodge that we're in in
an opportunity to have some of our
classroom functions out here at the
range along with our range activities
this Lodge was just built in though in
the fall and turned over this last
winter and so the spring was our first
classes out here at the range this is an
education center first and foremost this
year we have over 300 students in
firearms classes here at Hillsdale
College the shotgun teams was started
several years ago with students that
were here at college and had never even
shot a gun within the first two years
they won a division three national title
last year they were seventh and Division
two and due to some rural changes we
were back in Division three again this
year and
Division three national championship
again we have students now on the team
that are all Americans and and on the
Olympic team and things like that for
the facilities here at the at the range
we started off in 2008 with just one
trap field and now we have four American
trap fields out there we've also added a
five stand sporting clays field a skeet
field that is both American skeet and
international skeet this summer we are
going to add an olympic bunker trap the
only one in them in the state of
michigan and will serve the region well
we're also going to add an outdoor
Olympic archery range we're gonna start
this summer a building officer our West
with an indoor air gun and indoor
archery in an outdoor 100-meter pistol
in my voyage events that we're currently
doing here at the College range include
Constitution Day festival that is in the
fall where we have an open time for
people to come in and experience the
range and we have the range full of
instructors for those that need
instruction and and other opportunities
for those that are just coming in to
shoot for fun
we love to have visitors here at the
range you're always welcome come in and
come around the range I'll give you a
tour of it anytime that I come here our
students that come for a visit to campus
and come out here to the range this is a
highlight of their visit and will often
seal the deal
there's no college in the country that
has a facility like this